الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياضه صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
صدمات في يوم تعبئه جديد في فرنسا والحوار
طريقه مسدود والحكومه ترفض اللجوء للوساطه
ووزير الداخليه الفرنسيه يطالب بحل مجموعه
ثورات الارض اليساريه ويحملها مسؤوليه
العنف
واشنطن تكشف عن سباق تسلح في المحيط
الهادئ وتتهم بالسعي للهيمنه على المنطقه
خلال عشر الى 15 عاما
الرئيس الاسرائيلي يستدعي ممثلين عن
الائتلاف الحاكم والمعارضه لبحث ازمه
التعديلات القضائيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه لا صوت يعلو في
فرنسا فوق صوت الاحتجاجات ضد تعديل قانون
سن التقاعد المتواصله لليوم العاشر على
التوالي مظاهرات اليوم العاشر شهدت مشاركه
اكثر من نصف مليون متظاهر في مختلف المدن
الفرنسيه بحسب ما ذكرت صحيفه هذا واندلعت
اصطدامات في باريس ومدن اخرى بين الشرطه
والمتظاهرين كما تم استخدام الغاز المسيل
للدموع والهروات لتفريق الحشود
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولا يبدو بان الحكومه الفرنسيه عازمه على
التراجع عن قرارها بشان قانون التقاعد وهو
ما نقلته مصادر عن رئيسه الحكومه والتي
اكدت ان الحكومه لن تؤجل تطبيق اصلاح نظام
التقاعد من جهه ثانيه افادم رسل العربيه
بان نوابا من اليمين الوسط يعرضون التوسط
بين الحكومه الفرنسيه والنقابات اشار
مراسلنا الى ان النقابه عمال النظافه في
فرنسا اعلنت تعليق اضرابها اعتبارا من
الغد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مظاهر العنف المتزايده خلال الاحتجاجات في
فرنسا باتت تدعو الى القلق وهو ما دفع
الحكومه الفرنسيه الى دق ناقوس الخطر
وتوعد المشاغبين بعقوبات قاسيه بهذا
الخصوص اتهم وزير الداخليه الفرنسي
مجموعات من المحتجين بالتورط في اعمال عنف
ضخمه سابقا منها تدمير ممتلكات وابتزاز
قوات النظام مشيرا الى انه سيتقدم بحل
للاحتجاجات في اجتماع مجلس الوزراء المقبل
ارى العنف الشديده لبعض المجموعات الصغيره
كما ترونه انتم والتي اظهرت اجهزه
المخابرات انها مسجله منذ سنوات عديده
كمسؤوله عن اعمال عنف كبيره ومسؤوله عن
عمليات ابتزاز قويه ضد قوات النظام وتدمير
الممتلكات ووقوع مئات الجرحى من رجال
الشرطه نتيجه لتدميرهم لذلك قررت الشروع
في حل للاحتجاجات والذي ساقترحه في جلسه
اجتماع مجلس الوزراء المقبل
في تصعيد جديد نزول الاف من عناصر الشرطه
الفرنسيه الى الشوارع لكبح الاحتجاجات
تصعدون الحقه اوليفيي بالقول ان الحكومه
حصن ضد العنف غير المصبوق
المتظاهرون يوصلون اضرابهم ليصل الى قطع
الطرقات وازمه الوقود
تشير المعلومات الى نفاذ الوقود بنسبه 15%
من محطات الوقود في فرنسا اخر استطلاعات
الراي تؤكد تراجع شعبيه
في شهر واحد
ففي الوقت الذي يعتبر 30% ماكرون رئيسا
جيدا ينظر اليه 70 في المئه بسلبيه
النقبات لا تنوي التراجع وتحذر من خروج
الاحتجاجات عن السيطره وبينما تريد
النقابات مراسلات الا ان ادارته غير
متحمسه للوساطه
موقف يضع حكومه ماكرون في حرج اذا تراجعت
ستبدو ضعيفه
نتابع من باريس مع مدير مكتب العربيه في
فرنسا حسين قنيبر حسين اهلا بك معنا مع
نهايه اليوم العاشر من التظاهرات في فرنسا
احتجاجا على قانون التقاعد حجم وخارطه
تظاهرات هذا اليوم
مساء الخير صهيب ابدا بالجديد وهو العدد
الذي اعلنت عنه قبل دقائق من الان
النقابات العماليه التي اكدت ان الذين
نزلوا الى الشوارع عبر فرنسا هذا اليوم
بلغ عددهم مليونير شخص كانت النقابات
اعلنت بعد ظهر اليوم ان الذين تظاهروا في
باريس بلغ عددهم 450 الفا نتحدث عن
العاصمه وحدها والعدد الجديد الذي ورد قبل
دقائق يتعلق بعدد الذين تظاهروا عبر فرنسا
كلها وفقا للنقبات اما وزاره الداخليه
فتقول ان عدد الذين تظاهروا عبر فرنسا لا
يتجاوز
740 الفا من بينهم 93
بالنسبه لخارطه التظاهرات توزعت على باريس
ومونبوليي ومارسيليا واليوم وتولوز ونيس
وكان وليل
وعده مدن اخرى كبرى ومتوسطه وصغرى صهيب
مليونان متظاهر اذا اليوم خرجوا للشوارع
في فرنسا ما الفئات التي يضمها هذا الرقم
سمعنا اليوم عن فئات جديده التحقت
بالتظاهرات
فئه الشباب بشكل خاص كان حضورها كثيفا
تجاوز الخمسين في المئه من جمله
المتظاهرين وهذا يعكس رغبه متزايده في
صفوف الشباب للتعبير عن ارائهم الرافضه
لرفع سن التقاعد طبعا عندما نتحدث عن
الشباب هم مناصرون الاحزاب اليساريه بشكل
خاص وايضا الاعضاء في النقابات العماليه
طيب حسين ماكرون يحاجج والحكومه الفرنسيه
طبعا بان رفع سن التقاعد في فرنسا الى 64
عام ضروري لانقاذ البلاد من الافلاس بينما
النقابات وهذه الاعداد الغفيره تحتج على
هذا التعديل والحكومه متشبثه بهذا بهذا
القانون الجديد هل هناك مخرج
المخرج قد تتيحه احتمالات ثلاثه اما ان
راي المجلس الدستوري الذي سيصدر بعد ثلاثه
اسابيع لن يؤيد الحكومه في رفعها لسن
التقاعد وهذا امر مستبعد ولكنه ان حصل
سيكون له دور كبير في انهاء المشكله لكن
الارجح ان يؤيد المجلس الدستوري قرار
الحكومه بل قانون رفع سن التقاعد والفرضيه
الثانيه ان تتدخل جهه المال للتوسط بين
النقابات والحكومه فيتوصل الجانبان الى
تسويه مصادر حكوميه قالت الليله ان رئيسه
الوزراء ستستقبل في مطلع الاسبوع المقبل
ممثلين عن النقابات اما المخرج الثالث فقد
يؤمنه حوار مباشر بين النقبات والحكومه او
حوار غير مباشر تؤمنه مع هذه السيناريوهات
الحركيه او المخارج الثلاثه التي عدتها
يبدو ان الامور تجنح الى الهدوء ما مستقبل
الحركه الاحتجاجيه
تحالف النقابات اعلن الليله ان يوم تحرك
شعبي ونقابي واسع النطاق سيسجل يوم الخميس
في السادس من لسان ايبريل سيكون يوم
الاحتجاج الحادي عشر منذ بدء موجه
الاحتجاجات على رفع سن التقاعد ويتوقع ان
يشهد الخميس المقبل كما شهد هذا النهار
وايام التحرك السابقه التحركا عبر تظاهرات
واضرابات تسجل في باريس وعده مدن كبرى
تشمل عده قطاعات من بينها النقل والطاقه
والصحه والتعليم صهيب اذا الاحتجاجات
ستبقى مستمره حسين قنيبر مدير مكتب
العربيه في باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد يرفع الحد
الادنى لسن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
يفقد بعض العاملين في القطاع العام
امتيازاتهم
يرفع عدد سنوات العمل المطلوبه للتاهل
لمعاش تقاعدي كامل لماذا يهتم الفرنسيون
كثيرا بقانون التقاعد ينظر اليه كحجر
الزاويه لنموذج الحمايه الاجتماعيه
يدفع العاملون رسوم الرواتب لتمويل معاشات
المتقاعدين
يحصل جميع العمال الفرنسيين على معاش
تقاعديه
تعد فرنسا من الدول الاوروبيه التي تعتمد
ادنى سنا للتقاعد
حاول كافه الرؤساء المتعاقبين اجراء
تغييرات على قوانين التقاعد
غالبا تشعل غضب الشارع وتنعكس سلبا في
صناديق الاقتراع
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
تحذيرات من تمكن الذكاء الاصطناعي من
العالم ثلاث مئه مليون وظيفه مهدده حول
العالم
[موسيقى]
دكتور فريد شافييز السفير الاذري السابق
ورئيس مركز التحليل والعلاقات الدوليه
مرحبا بكم معنا دكتور فريد في اخبار
الساعه من العربيه في اي اطار يمكن وضع
محاوله الاغتيال هذه
دكتور فريد
دكتور فريد هل تسمعني
عضو البرلمان فضل مصطفى انتقد كثيرا ايران
في الشهور الماضيه
ودعاء الحكومه في اذربيجان للتصدي لبعض
المجموعات المتطرفه التي تعمل خارج
اذربيجان وبالتالي فهو تم ربطه مع الكثير
من التصريحات التي ادلى بها فضل مصطفى في
البرلمان وكذلك على قناه التلفزيون العامه
ضد ايران
هل يمكن من خلال هذا الحديث يعني ان تكون
ايران متورطه بشكل مباشر في التنفيذ
محاوله الاغتيال هذه داخل الاراضي
اذربيجان
يمكن ان نفترض ذلك على الرغم ان التحقيق
لا يزال جاريا وليس هناك نتائج
لهذا تحقيق والمراقبون يربطون ما حدث
بايران في ظل
العلاقات السائده بين ايران
اذربيجان وزاره الكثير من الحوادث داخل
اذربيجان كما تعرضت صفات اذربيجان في
طهران للهجوم وبالتالي منذ استقلال
اذربيجان قبل ثلاثين عاما انتقدت ايران
علانيه
اذربيجان في وسائل الاعلام
والايرانيه التي تتبنى موقفا معاديا
اذربيجان وفي هذا السياق بتاكيد نفكر
بجديه عن مصلحه من في محاوله اغتيال فضل
مصطفى وعلينا ان نراعي ايضا بان ايران قد
تسللت الى داخل اذربيجان ولديها بعض
الخلايا داخل اذربيجان وبالتالي يمكن ان
نفترض ان هذه الحوادث لها صله بايران وهذا
يشمل محاوله اغتيال فضل مصطفى دكتور فريد
في حال ما اذا اثبتت التحقيقات صحت هذه
الفرضيه وان ايران متورطه في محاوله
اغتيال النائب البرلماني الاذري ما الذي
سيترتب عليه ذلك في ضوء طبعا العلاقات
المتوتره اصلا بين طهران وباكو
فان العلاقات هي في ادنى مستوياتها بين
البلدين
واذربيجان اغلق التقارير من سفارتها في
ايران وليس هناك الكثير من العلاقات بين
البلدين وعلينا ان ناخذ في الحسبان
الخطابات الايرانيه ضد اذربيجان واعتقد
بالتالي ان الوضع سوف يزداد سوءا فيما يخص
العلاقات بين
اذربيجان وايران ولكن اذربيجان لن ترهبها
ايران وربما ينبغي ان ننظر في محاولاته
ايران
لكسر عزلتها وتحسين علاقاتها مع دول
الخليج مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
واستخدام هذا الزخم ليس حقيقه لتحسين
العلاقات مع الدول الجوار لان ما هذا سوى
تحرك تاكتيكي ترمي ايران من خلاله لربما
الوصول الى سلم في الجنوب والشمال ولكن
عندما تكون الاوضاع افضل فيما يتعلق
بمصالح ايران في جنوب القوقاز صدقني بان
ايران سوف تستهدف بلدان الخليج وكذلك في
الشرق الاوسط دكتور فريد
اذربيجانيه السابق ورئيس مركز التحليل
والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك على
انضمامك الينا من باكو
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه ان الوزير
فؤاد حسين امر باعاده القائم بالاعمال في
مملكه البحرين الى بغداد واضافت في بيان
على تويتر ان هذا الاجراء جاء تعزيزا
لمكانه الدبلوماسيه العراقيه التي تنتهجها
الوزاره في الحفاظ على الاعراف
الدبلوماسيه وزاره الخارجيه البحرينيه
اعلنت في وقت سابق انها استدعت القائمه
بالاعمال العراقيه مؤيد عمر عبد الرحمن
وسلمته مذكره احتجاج رسميه على ما وصفته
بانها مخالفاته المتكرره للاعراف
الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
في ظل ترقب متواصل لموعد بدايه ما سمي
بحرب الربيع الحاسمه تتواصل المعارك على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه في اهم الهجمات
الاخيره استهداف القوات الروسيه للعاصمه
كييف عن طريق مسيرات هذا ما كشف عنه رئيس
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه الذي اكد ان
قوته الجويه تصدت لهجوم روسي بالمسيرات
على مدينه كييف مشيرا الى ان الهجمات لم
تؤدي الى سقوط اصابات وقالت القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه ان روسيا اطلقت ما
مجموعه خمسه عشره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع
وفي اخر تطورات المعارك في المنطقه
الشرقيه وتحديدا في منطقه باخمت المتواصله
منذ اشهر قالت موسكو ان قوتها سيطرت على
المنطقه الصناعيه بالكامل لمدينه باخموت
وغير بعيد عن باخمت في
واصلت القوات الروسيه تقدمها سعيا للسيطره
على المدينه غير ان وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه من جهه هذاكره ان روسيا لم
تحقق سوى تقدم هاشم هامشي في الديافكا
مشيره الى انها خسرت الكثير من دباباتها
في مساعيها لحصار المدينه
لكن هل دفعت حده المعارك بعض قاده الجيش
الروسي الى الانقلاب على جنودهم نقلا عن
احد اعضاء وحده هجوميه الروسيه فان بعض
قاده الجيش الروسي باتوا يستخدمون ما
اسموه التكتيك الوحشي من خلال منع الجنود
من التراجع على الخطوط الاماميه للقتال
تقول صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
وفي التفاصيل قال احد جنود الوحده
العسكريه الروسيه المكونه من حوالي 20
رجلا ان قادتهم نشروا قوات لمنعهم من
التراجع وهددوهم بالقتل بعد ان تكبدوا
خسائر فادحه شرق اوكرانيا واضاف ان الوحده
كانت اتخذت قرارا بالعوده الى المقر لكن
القاده منعوهم من الاخلاء كما وضعوا حاجزا
خلفهم ولم يسمحوا لهم بالمغادره
[موسيقى]
وحول المحيط الهادي ايضا كشف رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه مارك ميلي عن سباق تسلح
غرب المحيط الهادئ وان الولايات المتحده
تراقب الوضع عن كثب رئيس الاركان قال ان
بكين تخطط للهيمنه على غرب المحيط الهادئ
خلال فتره تمتد من عشر الى 15 عاما دون ان
يقدم المزيد من التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
هدوء نسبي عاد الى اسرائيل بعد اعلان رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو تاجيل مشروع
الاصلاح القضائي بعد الاحتجاجات الكبيره
وفي اخر التطورات عوده وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي
المقال الى العمل بعد قرار التاجيل كما
ذكرت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان نتنياهو
بحث مع جالنت الوضع الامني في البلاد وكان
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قد اكدوا
بانه ما زال في منصبه حتى اشعار اخر وذلك
بعدما تسببت اقالته في تاجيج الازمه
السياسيه في البلاد وفي احدث خروج اعلامي
لها بعد قرار التاجيل اعلن نتنياهو ان
اسرائيل تعيش نقاشا هاما مؤكدا ثقته في
امكانيه الوصول الى اتفاقيات في النهايه
وبمجرد الاعلان عن اجراء التعديلات
القضائيه عدا الاستقرار مجددا الى
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي الذي كان قد اضطرب
بسبب هذه الاحتجاجات
رئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرتسوقي استدعى
ممثلين عن الائتلاف الحاكم وكذلك حزبي
المعارضه يشعتيد والوحده الوطنيه لاجراء
اول جلسه حوار بشان التشريع الخاص
بالتعديلات القضائيه الذي فجر ازمه في
اسرائيل وحسب صحافه الاسرائيليه فقد منع
المدعي العام بنيامين نتنياهو من تمثيل
حزب الليكود في هذا الحوار التشريعي
اكد البيت الابيض انه لا خطط لاستقبال
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
وقال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي في
البيت الابيض ان امريكا لم تبلغ اسرائيل
بتفاصيل اي تسويه للازمه الحاليه الا انها
تشدد على ضروره ان تراعي هذه التسويه
التوازنات في البلاد الى ذلك قال السفير
الامريكي في اسرائيل لم تتدخل في
الاحتجاجات وذلك بعد اتهامات من اليمين
الاسرائيلي
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
دور عالمي للنظام السوري في تجاره
الكبتاجون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد من المدينه المنوره الى
العالم هو اخر المشاريع التطويريه التي
شهدتها المنطقه المركزيه بالمسجد النبوي
والذي يقع على مساحه 20000 متر مربع ويضم
ثمانيه عشر مطبخا من مختلف البلدان
الاسلاميه التي تتناسب مع كافه اذواق
الزائرين طوال شهر رمضان التفاصيل برفقه
الزميل سلطان السلامي
[موسيقى]
المدينه المنوره تعتبر ثاني اهم مدينه
للعالم الاسلامي حيث تضم المسجد النبوي
وقبر النبي محمد حيث يفد اليها سنويا اكثر
من ثمانيه ملايين مسلم من شتى بقاع الارض
الان المنطقه صارت جدا جدا مكتظه بالحجاج
والمعتمرين التوجيه صار على جهه واحده
تركيز الحجاج كلهم صار على جهه واحده
المساحات صارت اكبر تعدد الثقافات
فرصه تجاره جدا جدا كويسه في المنطقه هذه
من المدينه المنوره الى العالم هو عنوان
مشروع المنطقه المركزيه المجاور للمسجد
النبوي الذي يقع على مساحه
20,000 متر مربع ويضم 18 مطبخا من مختلف
البلدان الاسلاميه
لتتناسب مع كافه اذواق الزائرين طوال شهر
رمضان اضافه الى مركز استعلامات
ومحل لبيع التذكارات ومسارات مهيئه الى
ساحات المسجد الحقيقه المكان رائع جدا هذه
الاختلاف
التعدد الدول بالاكلات والمطاعم الرقابه
الجميله الرائعه جدا يعني واحد من ياكل
مامن انه مطمئنه اني اكل هنا بهذا الاماكن
هي جوار وطمانينه هي مدينه الرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام فاني لمست هاي الطمانينه
اللي احنا افتقدناها لسنوات طويله بالعراق
لكن اذا احب اشتري اشياء تذكاريه اشياء
كثيره يعني اشياء السجادات الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
السلاسل الاسلاميه انا احب اكون اولادي
يتذكرون العمره اللي اني سويتها باشياء
جميله بيها طابع تراثي سعودي اسهمت
المشروعات الحديثه التي انجزت في المنطقه
المركزيه بالمدينه المنوره في تحسين
المشهد الحضري ورفع مستوى جوده الحياه في
الطرق والشوارع المحيطه
وتهيئهها بشكل اكبر للمشاه وقاصدي المسجد
النبوي الشريف من المدينه المنوره سلطان
السلمي العربيه
ومن الحرم النبوي نذهب الى الحرم المكي
الان من هناك معنى هاني صفيان مراسل
العربيه هاني اهلا بك مما اشاهد يبدو انك
من احد المخارج المخصصه لخروج المعتمرين
من الحرم المكي باتجاه مقرات اقامتهم كيف
يتم تسيير عمليه الخروج خاصه في ظل
الاعداد الكبيره من المعتمرين في شهر
رمضان
صحيح صهيب اهلا بك والهم بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه بالفعل نحن في نقطه من او منطقه
من المناطق التي خصصتها السعوديه والجهات
الامنيه لخروج المعتمرين والمصليين باتجاه
الحافلات التي تقل هؤلاء المعتبرين
والمصلين الى مقر اقامتهم وتحديدا الى
المواقف المخصصه هناك تسع مواقف خصصتها
السعوديه من اجل
سهوله ويسر ايضا تحرك المعتمرين والمصلين
والتوجه بهم ونقلهم عبر الحافلات طبعا
المشهد الذي تشاهده امامي الان ومشاهدي
قناه العربيه هو استمرار عمليه خروج
المعتمرين والمصلين بعد ادائهم لصلاه
التراويح في الجهه اليمنى الان ويلتقطها
الزبيل المصور اجمل واحده من المخارج
وكذلك بعض الممرات التي خصصتها الجهات
الامنيه حتى تكون فقط مخصصه
للذين يرغبون والممر الاخر لمن يرغب ايضا
بالدخول طبعا في الساحه اليمنى التي
تشاهدها هذه الدعم تفضل عذرا على المقاطعه
ونحن نتابع معك المشهد اللافت يعني عدد
كبير من المعتمرين في شهر رمضان هذا العام
مقارنه بالاعوام الماضيه طبعا ونشاهد الان
الصوره امام الكعبه المشرفه طبعا صحن
الطواف يكاد يمتلئ بالكامل في هذا الشهر
الفضيل هذا الموسم طبعا هذا بعد عدد
السلطات السعوديه للطاقه الاستيعابيه
الكامله كذلك حدثنا عن التسهيلات والى ما
يرجع ارتفاع اعداد المعتمرين في هذه
الايام الاولى من شهر رمضان
طبعا التسهيلات التي قدمتها السعوديه قبل
قليل انها كنا نتحدث مع احد المعتمرين ما
هو الفرق الذي شاهدته هي اتاحه نظام
التاشيره ودخول التاشيره بالنسبه الى
المعتمرين وكذلك لزوار المسجد الحرام خاصه
ممن رغدوا بالوصول سواء في موسم رمضان او
غير موسم رمضان بخلاف ما كان او ما كانت
عليه الاعوام الماضيه من خلال يجب على
المعتمر او ممن يرغب الذهاب الى مكه
المكرمه او تحديد المسجد الحرام يجب ان
يقدم اوراقه وكذلك
المستلزمات والاحتياجات التي يرغبها عبر
مكتب خدمات طبعا ثلاث طوابق التي نشاهدها
الان وايضا يلتقطها نشاهد الطاقه
الاستيعابيه بالكامل نحن فقط نرصد ثلاث
طوابق طبعا هذه ثلاث طوابق فقط التي خصصت
لي المسعى بعد اداء المعتمرين الطواف
يذهبون الى المسعى
وهي من ضمن ايضا الجنود السعوديه التي
قدمته بالفعل يعني هذه الاعداد الكبيره من
المعتمرين في عمليه يعني نحن في ما نزل في
العشر الاوائل من رمضان يعني والعشر
الاواخر يعني بالعاده تشهد اقبالا متزايدا
اكثر من المعتمرين وامام هذه التسهيلات
التي قدمتها السلطات السعوديه
ما المتوقع وما الخطه كذلك على مدار ايام
الشهر الفضيل
طبعا هذا العام قد يكون مختلف تماما
الطاقه للسعوديه التي كانت تسجل في
الاعوام الماضيه ما قبل ازمه كورونا من
مليون ونصف الى مليون
معتمر كانوا تحديدا فقط يقفون في ليله 27
يتوقع ان يكون هذا العام يتجاوز العدد الى
اكثر من ثلاثه مليون ونصف المليون معتمر
فقط في ليله واحده طبعا هذه الاستعدادات
وهذه التجهيزات هي استعدت بها السعوديه في
وقت مبكر وكذلك هي
وضعت خطط ايضا اخرى وبديله في حاله ايضا
كان ارتفع العدد الى اكثر من هذا العالم
ونصف يعني هو يعادل عدد الحجاج يعني في
ليله 27 اذا كل عام وانت بخير نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الصوره الحيه اذا مباشره
من الحرم المكي هاني صفيه المراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا زياد رائحه مخدر الكبتاجون بدات تفوح
من سوريا فالبلد اصبح يطلع بدور عالمي
كبير في انتاج هذا المخدر والذي يتم تهريب
معظمه عبر لبنان والكلام هنا منقول عن
الخزانه الامريكيه الاخيره اصدرت عقوبات
على سته اشخاص مرتبطين بالنظام السوري
لتورطهم في التجاره الكبتاجون وشملت لائحه
العقوبات اربعه من حلفاء عائله الرئيس
السوري بشر الاسد وثلاثه من اللبنانيين
الضالعين في الامر اشارت الوزاره الى ان
بعض مهربين مخدرات اللبنانيين لديهم صلات
مع ميليشيا حزب الله ويلعبون بدورهم دورا
في تسهيل تصدير هذا المخدر
[موسيقى]
التطور التكنولوجي واصل تهديد اليد
العامله حول العالم في ظل اللجوء المتزايد
الى الذكاء الاصطناعي فنقلا عن تقرير
لمصرف جودمان ما يقرب من ثلثي الوظائف في
الولايات المتحده واوروبا معرضه لدرجه
معينه من التحول بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي في
ذات السياق اشارت صحيفه فاناشي الامريكيه
الى ان التطور التكنولوجي سيعرض نحو 300
مليون عامل بدوام كامل في الاقتصادات
الكبيره لخطر فقدان عمله لكن الصحيفه
تحدثت في الوقت نفسه عن ايجابيات التطور
التكنولوجي هذا حيث اشارت ان انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي يمكن ان تؤدي الى طفره انتاجيه
من شانها زياده الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
العالمي السنوي بنسبه سبعه في المئه على
مدى 10 سنوات
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين
صدامات في يوم تعبئه جديد في فرنسا
والحوار طريقه مسدود والحكومه ترفض اللجوء
للوساطه
ووزير الداخليه الفرنسيه يطالب بحل مجموعه
ثورات الارض اليساريه ويحملها مسؤوليه
العنف
واشنطن تكشف عن سباق تسلح في المحيط
الهادئ وتتهم بكين بالسعي للهيمنه على
المنطقه خلال 15 عاما
الرئيس الاسرائيلي يستدعم ممثلين عن
الائتلاف الحاكم والمعارضه لبحث ازمه
التعديلات القضائيه
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]